regex is a tool to find different
patterns and text and it can speed up
your workflow if you do any kind of data
cleaning or data scraping
in this video i'm going to cover just
the basics of regex but in the next
video i'm going to go over some examples
of how i use regex to extract data and
to web scrape
rugex is supported by a lot of text
editors so in vs code for example if you
hit control f to find
there should be an icon to enable regex
patterns but we're going to be using
this website called regex 101 which is
great for beginners because it helps
explain your regex patterns
and it's also pretty powerful for doing
text cleaning so let's learn some
regular expressions
we're first going to start out with
character classes which allow us to
specify the type of character that we're
looking for
slash w matches a word character this
includes letters numbers and underscores
so if we're searching for all instances
of gray both with an a and with an e
we can put a slash w for the third
character and that'll return all
variants of gray but it technically also
matches words that start with gr and end
with y
but just like normal letters you can put
these character class elements together
to make a sequence
so if we're looking for all three letter
words that start with d we could do d
slash w w and that would just give us
dog
this isn't the best way of writing it
but we'll touch on that more in a bit
the next character class is slash d
which matches numbers so it's similar to
slash w but only matches numbers and not
letters or underscores
so if we're trying to select all the
phone numbers that are formatted like
this with the hyphens
we would do three slash d's and then
hyphen and then
three more a hyphen and then four of
them and like i said this isn't the best
way to write this but we're going to
cover that in a sec
you'll see though that it's matching our
three phone numbers that are all
formatted this way
slash s matches a white space character
so spaces
tabs and new lines in regex 101 you
might not be able to see the new lines
highlighted in blue
because they're technically not visible
but you will see that it is a match and
the last character class we're going to
cover is the period which is the wild
card
it will match any character so letters
numbers spaces and even special
characters but not new lines
so if i wanted to match all of these
words i could do b e period t
and it would select the words even with
a number in the middle or a space or a
question mark what if we want to be more
selective about our pattern matching in
the first example if i really only
wanted the occurrence of gray
and gray with an a and an e how would i
write that in regex luckily we have
groups to match a more specific subset
of characters the square brackets work
as an or
so it'll match one occurrence of any of
the letters in the brackets
so to find just our two versions of gray
we could search for gr
and then ae in brackets and y
and that'll only match those two words
and nothing else you can also negate
what's inside the brackets by adding a
carrot at the beginning
and then it's like having a wild card
here that'll match anything except for
what's in the brackets
the other type of regex group are the
parentheses we can do a similar thing to
select
our two versions of gray the only
difference is now we need to use the
pipe operator to specify the ore
so this is what it would look like if we
wanted to select gray and gray
but with parentheses we're not just
restricted to matching with one
character
we can have whole strings within our
parentheses so if i wanted to search for
all versions of there i could start out
with th e and then in parentheses
we could do one with yre then add the or
do one with ir
then add another or and then do one with
re and you see that'll select all three
versions of there but now you'll notice
that the text that was in parentheses is
now highlighted in green here and it's
being captured
capturing text like this with
parentheses is actually really helpful
when we want to do find and replace
operations because we can reference the
text that's being
captured just to illustrate what i mean
let's go back to the phone number
example so here we're back to capturing
our phone numbers
and let's put parentheses just around
our area code now within regex 101 we
can go to
substitution here and then for the
substitution we could say
the area code is and we can reference
this first capture group
by doing dollar sign one and now you see
what our substitution would look like
and to go a step further we can actually
nest these capture groups within each
other
so if we want to select the area code as
one capture group but then
the whole phone number as the other
capture group we can now reference both
of them
and make this the area code of the full
phone number which is the first capture
group
is the second capture group and now you
see what our respective text looks like
but again writing out the slash d
10 times is pretty inefficient and
that's why regex has quantifiers
these don't work as individual
components like the way we'd have a
character class by itself
instead it quantifies the character
directly before it whether it's a
character class or a specific letter or
number or anything
so the first quantifier is the curly
braces where we can specify
a min and a max and it's essentially
saying that that character will show up
between
n and m times so if we're looking for a
character that shows up between one to
five times we would do
one comma five what's really powerful
here is that if we're looking for at
least
n occurrences we don't even need to
specify the upper bounds so we could
write
n comma and if we want exactly n
occurrences we would write just
n without the comma and without the
upper bound so i added another phone
number down here that has four digits to
begin with so let's see if we can make a
regex pattern that's efficient and
selects all these phone numbers again
we'll do slash d but now
that can occur either three times or
four times
then there's a hyphen and then another
number that occurs three times
a hyphen and then another number that
occurs four times
and now you see we get all of our phone
numbers and it's a lot more readable to
write it like this
there are a few other quantifiers as
well if we want our regex to be less
wordy but functionality
wise the curly braces can actually cover
all scenarios so the star or asterisk
means the character will appear 0 or
more times so this is the equivalent of
writing
0 comma in the curly braces so if we
wanted to select all of our hello
strings in its entirety we would write
hello
and then the exclamation mark at the end
now with the star because we know that
it'll be at least
zero times but could be any number the
plus means the character will appear one
or more times
so this is the equivalent of writing one
comma in the curly braces if we got rid
of the star and made it a plus
you see that it doesn't select this last
hello because it requires there to be at
least one exclamation mark
and the last quantifier we're gonna
cover is the question mark which means
either zero or one occurrence so it's
either there or it isn't and this is the
same as writing
0 comma 1 or just comma 1. if we make
this a question mark at the end
now the exclamation point may or may not
be there and you see that it won't
select the exclamation points
towards the end of these first two
strings another class of regex
characters are the anchors
so if you have a piece of text that
occurs specifically at the beginning or
end of a line you can use anchors to
help you search for that pattern the
carrot specifies that the character
comes at the beginning of the string
here we want to select the text each
time
alice is talking and everything she says
but we don't want to select where alice
is being mentioned in the conversation
by bob
so we'll start out with the carrot so
regex knows that we want the beginning
of the string
and then we'll write alice with the
colon and we essentially don't know what
she'll say afterwards
so we're going to put a period down and
we want this to go to the end of the
line and we don't know how many
characters it'll be
so we'll use an asterisk and also a
quick thing about regex 101 is that
there are different search modes and in
this case it's treating each new line as
a separate string with its own beginning
and its own end theoretically we could
treat this as one giant string by
going over here and disabling multi-line
and you can see now it's only selecting
that very first
question we're going to change this back
to multi-line though now the opposite of
the carrot
is the dollar sign which specifies that
the character right before
it comes at the end of the string so
we'd put this at the end of our search
pattern and that would signal that
that's what the string ended with so if
we only wanted to select questions that
alice was asking
we could modify our search pattern and
make it a
slash question mark and then a dollar
sign and now you see we're only
selecting questions
what's tricky here is that you'll notice
that i put the slash right before the
question mark
and that's so regex knows that we're
looking for an actual question mark and
not just using one as part of our search
pattern
this right here is called an escape
character and we have to use it anytime
we're
trying to search for a special character
that regex reserves for its other
functions
so question marks periods dollar signs
etc but that really covers the basics of
reg x and should be good enough for the
majority of text cleaning or data
scraping that you're doing there are
plenty of more advanced concepts and if
you're interested in learning about
those i'd recommend checking out this
tutorial which i'll link in the
description
additionally i find that this regex
cheat sheet is pretty helpful if you've
got the basics down but still want a
refresher and check out part two of this
video where i cover some concrete data
cleaning and web scraping examples using
regular expressions thanks for watching
and i'll catch
the next one